pour en parler nous sommes avec philippe
gosselin et député l'ère de la manche
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec moi en
direct sur arte france savoir on connaît
quand même le mode de communication du
président de la république son
engagement aussi très fort en faveur de
la vaccination
finalement on a raison peut-être de se
poser aussi cette question est ce que le
tollé autour des propos d' emmanuel
macron sont justifiées
écoutez moi je crois qu'un président de
la république emmanuel macron en
particulier il est le gardien de l'unité
de la nation il est le gardien aussi de
la concorde de public et je crois qu'il
n'appartient pas au président de la
république de de permettre à nos
concitoyens de s'affronter enfin on a
aujourd'hui des braises qui sont très
rouge c'est pas la peine de souffler
dessus et moi je reviens sur
l'intervention du président il y a à peu
près un mois fin à trois semaines
maintenant où il disait la main sur le
coeur j'ai beaucoup appris je n'aurais
pas dû faire de petites phrases et bien
est-ce qu'il est digne de la fonction
présidentielle d'aller dire qu'on
emmerde les non vaccinés les
non-vaccinés c'est peut-être des
antilles fax oui mais ce sont aussi des
millions de personnes qui ont la peur au
ventre qui qui savent pas trop s'ils
doivent se faire vacciner les canaris ce
qu il prenne il n'y a pas que des
mauvais citoyen et lui il aimait
directement au placard leur rei
finalement leur raison d'être je trouve
que c'est pas normal ce n'est pas digne
encore une fois ce sont des propos de
dérapage il mesure est bien évidemment
ils ont été pesées personne ne doute que
cette interview n'est pas été relu par
les services de l'elysée donc c'est un
jeu très dangereux sans doute aussi à
double détente qu'il s'agit peut-être de
mettre les oppositions en porte à faux
et donc tout ça va souder dans un
premier temps autour du président de la
république les pros vaccin la majorité
bien sûr qui hier avait beaucoup de mal
à avaler les choses mais aujourd'hui qui
apparaît comme ressouder et c'est une
partie de nos concitoyens 10h et une
autre qui va être gentiment envoyé vers
zemmour ou le pen et voilà ce que
souhaite le président de la fédé
mitterrand
matière glick alors pour contextualiser
les propos du président de la république
qui répondait donc à une question d'une
journaliste
qui
soulignait justement que les non
vaccinés occupe 85% les réanimations ce
qui entraîne du coup un report des
réanimations dit les propos du président
vous pensez que c'est une déclaration de
guerre contre les non vaccinés ces
calculs et intentionnelle réellement
c'est une vraie déclaration de guerre
ses calculs et évidemment je ne peux pas
penser que le président de la république
ne calcule pas ce qu'il dit ou n'est pas
la mesure de ce qu'il dit ou alors c'est
encore plus grave maintenant encore une
fois personne ne conteste l'intérêt de
la vaccination vendée tous vaccinés ici
ça n'empêche pas d'attraper la coded on
sait bien ça empêche les cas les plus
graves et c'est heureux et personne ne
dit aujourd'hui il n'y a pas un nombre
trop important de non vaccinés dans les
services de réanimation et moins je
salue le travail des soignants qui est
extrêmement difficile dans ces
conditions une partie de leur
découragement mais pour autant je crois
qu'il faut mieux convaincre il faut
tendre la main plutôt que d'insulter à
ce point les concitoyens non vacciné je
crois que là la stratégie est très très
très mauvaise savez la stratégie je
pense qu'elle est de prendre à témoin le
client public on lance le boomerang pour
attraper les électeurs mais parfois le
boomerang il rate sa cible et le
boomerang on se prend dans la figure
pour ne pas employer un terme vulgaire
comme les utilisent le président de la
république par les simples c'est bien
par les peuples c'est bien il ya un
moment où on peut dire prendre des
fonctions il ya beaucoup de commentaires
dans les rangs de l'opposition on peut
citer celle de votre candidate pour la
présidentielle valérie pécresse qui a
indiqué affirmé ce matin qu'il fallait
qu'il faudra mettre fin à ce quinquennat
du mépris quel est le message que vous
vous adressez vous aux non vaccinés
justement donc c'est bien le message
on a des chiffres catastrophiques
le message c'est de leur faire
comprendre qu'ils risquent non seulement
là t d autres mais leur propre leur
propre santé ça c'est important de faire
passer ce message qu'ils empêchent aussi
un certain nombre de nos concitoyens de
pouvoir être opéré d'avoir un traitement
comme il le faudrait hospitalier
d'opérations je pense à des cancers qui
ne se prend pas aujourd'hui le traité et
c'est mémé allons vers eux faisons du
porte à porte l'assurance maladie à la
lutte et ceux qui ne sont pas vaccinés
on peut les appeler en les harcelant je
peux essayer de les convaincre voilà ce
qu'il faut faire plutôt que d'essayer de
les mettre ou pas de la société on
l'aimé déjà au banc de la société parce
qu'ils pourront pas aller dans des
sorties culturelles et spectateurs c'est
une chose non les plus on les pointe
comme étant des non citoyens c'est au
smic l'autre partie de l'interview du
président ce ne sont plus des citoyens
c'est très grave nous avons un
département comme la seine saint denis
vous avez 20 % de la population qui
n'est pas vacciné qui a pillé aussi un
lourd tribut en termes de morts et on va
dire qu'il ya 20% de la population c'est
lui qui n'est pas citoyenne donc non
encore une fois on sommes dans une
démarche collective qui est difficile on
peut avoir d autres positions des
divergences mais je crois qu'on peut pas
faire que les lives et par jean la
société comme ça aujourd'hui un conseil
à nouveau conseil de défense sanitaire
se tient avec un conseil des ministres
dans la foulée et les débats sur le
texte concernant le pass vaccinale
doivent reprendre normalement cet après
midi est-ce que les propos finalement du
président de la république risque de
menacer ce texte écoutez je ne vois pas
comment le texte ne serait pas adopté
une fille née il ya une majorité qui est
favorable là il ya des péripéties parce
que ça n'a pas d'autres mots c'est même
une une crise un peu politique qui met
en difficulté le président par rapport à
sa majorité qui hier soir était quand
même bien démunis alors aujourd'hui tout
le monde remonte au créneau on resserre
les rangs je peux vous dire qu'il ya
soit cette nuit il y avait beaucoup
collègues en match était complètement
députés et il désapprouvait les propos
du fait de la république on peut
imaginer cet après midi à 15h à la
reprise des travaux avoir encore des
tensions le texte va continuer à avancer
il ya des amendements qui concerne les
mineurs on en a déjà parlé hier on était
arrivé à une approche à défaut d'être
totalement consensuel qui était
constructive à plaisait on a encore des
questions qui concernent les contrôles
par les airs style et restaurateurs on a
aussi des questions sur les délais
d'application de ce texte que nous
examinons parce que pour le moment la
fin c'est le faire fait il faut compter
qu'on fixe une date de fin le droit
d'exception on nous propose ça ne peut
pas devenir le droit normal du quotidien
pendant des années on peut pas
déséquilibrer à ce point ou deux filles
un certain nombre de vie personnelle de
nicolas yves culturales et qu'on ait un
meilleur équilibre entre la protection
indispensable de nos concitoyens c'est
évident mais aussi un certain nombre de
respect de droits importants de liberté
importante c'est cet équilibre qui
craque dans la durée nos concitoyens
aura confiance dans la vaccination
auront confiance aussi dans la parole
est aujourd'hui en réalité tout ça
bouscule tout le monde a tout simplement
les autres conditions c'est toute la
classe politique ne trouve malmené d'une
certaine façon en difficulté avec les
propos du président de la république ça
il en est responsable
ce ne sont pas les oppositions qui
détiennent la clé merci beaucoup à vous
filer gosselin l avoir répondu en direct
à nos questions sur rt france je
rappelle que vous êtes député les
républicains de la manche merci à vous